hey rick you following what's happening
in thailand
some kids stuck in a cave
[Music]
we're on the list of rescue divers
it's just a tourist cave it looks easy
but when it's flooded it's impossible
it takes a certain kind of mindset for
the deep cave diving you have to be a
bit nuts
they're very very dangerous
high water level and the law with
stability barely shoulder-wide pulling
against very strong cameras
last seen nine days ago twelve boys and
their coach are trapped in the flooded
caves
hello
hey
we're here
how many of you 13
13. they're all alone uh can we
go out now
[Music]
you try and dive those kids the whole
way all you'd be bringing out is dead
bodies
with oxygen running low the entire
nation is anxiously waiting for what
will happen next
what are you thinking
just a crazy idea
what a skill none of the rest of us have
no
it's insane it's unethical it's illegal
man's already died
but do nothing we'll be bringing them
out there for sure
so you are expecting casualties
yes
i expected
[Music]
johnny okay
yeah i'm okay just give me a minute
[Music]
okay
we can make it
[Music]
you